[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سي
ابي عاصي بينما احدثكم الان تتفاعل الكثير
من الاحداث حول العالم هذه اللقطات من
العاصمه البولنديه ورسو التي تعيش على وقع
زياره للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وفيها
القى خطابا بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا وبشان
وحده نيكو
ومن مجلس الامن في نيويورك نتابع هذه
اللقطات حيث من المقرر ان تعقد جلسه
لمناقشه مقاله موسكو انها معلومات جديده
متعلقه بما تصفه بالتخريب الذي ادى الى
تعطيل خطوط انابيب نوت ستريم
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
عشيه دخولها عامها الثاني الحرب في
اوكرانيا بين خطابين من وارسو بايدن يتحدث
عن جبهه موحده للنيتو وتماسك في موقف
الدعم لكياف ومن موسكو بوتين يتهم الغرب
بخوض حرب ضد بلاده ويعلق المشاركه في
معاهده الحد من الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
واشنطن تصفها بالخطوه المؤسفه والامم
المتحده تقول ان العالم دون تدابير
السيطره على الاسلحه النوويه بات اكثر
خطوره
على الرغم من تصدر الميليشيا المشهد
الميداني بوادر خلاف وانقسام تطفو على سطح
العلاقه بين فاغنر ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه
مؤسس المجموعه يتهم وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان الروسيين بالخيانه العظمى ويقول
انهما اصدر اوامر بعدم تزويد مقاتله
بالذخيره والدفاع الروسيه تقول ان
التصريحات بشان نقص الذخيره لدى القوات
المتطوعه غير صحيح
تركيا وسوريا على وقع مشهد الزلزال
المتكرر اداره الكوارث والطوارئ في انقره
تقول ان عدد قتل الزلزال تجاوز
42,300 وبعد رصد نحو تسعه ملايين سوري
متضرر من الكارثه مسؤوله امميه تقول ان
النداء الاممي للاستجابه للكارثه في سوريا
ممول بنسبه لا تتجاوز 17%
مع تزايد الجدل بشان حمله الايقافات في
تونس نقابه الصحفيين تقول ان نقيب
الصحفيين وناشطين استدعوا للتحقيق على
خلفيه مشاركتهم في احتجاج ضد الاستفتاء
على الدستور في يوليو الماضي وبعد مثوله
للتحقيق مجددا الغنوشي يقول ان الانقلاب
يستهدف كل الكيانات الوطنيه وسعيد يؤكد ان
تونس لن تقبل التدخل الخارجي
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تصريحات
بشان توتر العلاقه مع وزير الدفاع الروسي
التي اتهم فيها وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
اركان القوات الروسيه بمحاوله تدمير
مجموعته وحرمانها من الذخيره واصفا الامر
بالخيانه العظمى لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في
رايكم الى اي مدى ستشكل تصريحات مؤسسي
فاجنر بوابه للانقسام مع المؤسسه العسكريه
الروسيه وقد جاءت النتيجه على النحو
التالي نحو 22% قالوا انها بدايه للانقسام
والتخلي عن فاجنر بينما قال قرابه 78% ان
هذا الخلاف سيتم تجاوزه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد نحو عام على حربها في اوكرانيا روسيا
واسئله الاقتصاد الصعبه
[موسيقى]
بين خطابين هكذا بدل مشهد بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده على وقع الحرب في
اوكرانيا خطاب في موسكو للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين قال عنه الكريملين ان
العالم اجمع سيدرس محتواه وخطاب للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن تحدث فيه بقوه باسم
بلاده وباسم حلف النيتو خطاب من وسط وارسو
التي كانت يوما ما مقرا لحلفا قادته روسيا
مبارزه المثيره على المسرح الدولي جعلت
اوكرانيا بين خطابين عشيه الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للحرب من موسكو تحدث الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ومن وارسو الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن خطابان متضادان في كل شيء الا في
تاكيدهما ان الحرب مستمره بل هي قد ترتاد
في عامها الثاني مربعات جديده من التصعيد
هي مبارزه مشحونه بالرموز والدلالات تذكر
باشد ساعات الحرب البارده توترا خاصه
وانها استحضرت كل عناصر تلك المرحله
الصعبه على اوروبا والعالم
فوارسو عاصمه بولندا التي تحدث منها
الرئيس الامريكي هي نفسها التي كانت ذات
يوم مقر حلفوارسو حلف المنظومه الشرقيه
انذاك في مقابل حلف الناتو المظله
العسكريه للحلفاء هل اراد بوتين اثاره
الغرب اكثر بتعليق اهم اتفاقيه معه ام كان
قراره فعلا لحمايه بلاده
مضطر اليوم للاعلان عن تعليق روسيا
مشاركتها في معاهده تقليص الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه والهجوميه لا ننسحب من
المعاهده بل نعلق مشاركتنا ويجب ان تكون
وزاره الدفاع وشركه الاستعداد لاختبار
الاسلحه النوويه اذا بدات الول المتحده
بذلك
ثم هل تعمد بايدن هذه المره ان يكون في
منطقه الحرب وغير بعيد من موسكو امعانا في
تحديها مسار رحلته من واشنطن الى ومنها
الى وارسو يمكن ان يحيل الى ذلك في لحظه
بدات فيها حرب اوكرانيا اشبه بحرب امريكيه
روسيه راسها بوتين وبايدن وهو ما قد يجعل
وقفها
رهنا بايديهما ايضا
ينضم الينا من واشنطن جونسون الدبلوماسي
الامريكي السابق ومدير شؤون روسيا
والاستقرار الاستراتيجي في معهد الولايات
المتحده للسلام ومن موسكو معنى ديمتري
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما
كيف قيمت ما ورد في خطاب الرئيس الروسي
بعد عام على الحرب وما ابرز الرسائل التي
توقفت عندها في هذا الخطاب
وكثير من الاسئله بقيت دون اجوبه مثلا
المجال والمدى
والحقيقي وحدود العمليه العسكريه تقوم بها
روسيا حاليا ولكن كما
الشهير
الحرب مثل الحرب تغير لونها حسب درجه
النجاح وعدم التوفر نجاح لدى كل جانب
وبالتالي النتيجه ستقرر على الارض
روسيا ارادت ان تجروا فوضات وقالت هناك
السنه الماضيه لكن الجانب الاوكراني
غادرها في شهر مارس اذار في اسطنبول
ومن ذلك النبي حصل ايه اتصال حقيقي بين
روسيا
واوكرانيا لحل هذه المشكله الدبلوماسيه
جبهات الاخرى اعتقد
كان هناك ثقه كبيره بالنفس في هذا في
الخطاب للسيد بوتين اذ قال بان روسيا
ستمضي في طريقها بصرف النظر عن الغرب وكان
تقدم انتقادات كثيره ضد الغرب وادارهم
اعطيكم الفكره الرئيسه كانت الانفصال
الانفصال عن الاوروبي والابتعاد عنه
والابتعاد عن الولايات المتحده لكن بوتين
قال ووضح بان هذا ليس خيارنا نحن بل هذا
كان هو قرار القاده الغربيين الذين يقومون
منذ مده
سياسه معاديه لروسيا على الاقل منذ نهايه
التسعينيات وفي هذا الوضع نجد ان روسيا لم
يكنوا بكل بساطه لديها اي خيار سوى
الابتعاد عنهم في اكثر من مره خلال الخطاب
الرئيس الروسي دعنا نسال السيد
عن ايضا تقييمه لخطاب الرئيس الروسي
ولخطاب الرئيس الامريكي
الذي قدمه الرئيس الامريكي لاوكرانيا
ونظرته الى مستقبل النيتو
علي ان اختلف اولا مع زميل الروسي ما
رايناه في الايام الاربعه الماضيه كان
حمله دبلوماسيه مذهله ضد روسيا وغزوها في
لاوكرانيا في ميونخ وفياب واليوم في بورصه
هذا الانفصال الذي تحدث عنه كان سببه
روسيا وخيار روسيا بسبب غزوها الوحشي لو
ان الغرب يتصرف كردات شعر ازاء جرائم حرب
وازامه ازاء غزو هذا استجابه للقانون
الدولي كان قرار بوتين اولا ويقع كذلك اين
تتجه روسيا اذا كان خياره كما قال زميلنا
من موسكو الانفصال والابتعاد هذا خيار
معروفه هذه وجهه النظر هذه ولكن انا اسالك
في مناسبه بمناسبه مرور عام على هذه الحرب
اسالك عن تقييمك
لخطاب بوتين وخطاب بايدن وهل
سيؤديان الى اختلاف النتائج في المرحله
المقبله
نعم سيد جنسن
نعم اعتقد ان خطاب بايدن كان خطابا ملهما
واعاد التاكيد على وحده التحالف ضد
روسيا لصالح اوكرانيا لو ان احدا شك في ان
هذا التحالف سيتردد في دعم اوكرانيا راينا
في الايام الاربعه الماضيه خلافه ذلك اما
خطاب بوتين لم يحمل جديدا كان اعاده لامور
مكرره في السابق وكل من كان يشاهده يحضره
عرف ذلك
توتن يلعب لعبه خاسره وروسيا تواجهه
التقاط المتزايد بسبب حربها في اوكرانيا
هذه العم العسكريه سيد متري بدات وكما ذكر
اليوم ايضا واعاده تذكير بوتين بسبب توسع
الناتو اليوم الرئيس الامريكي يتعهد
بتعزيز الحدود الشرقيه
وبمزيد من الدعم لاوكرانيا الا تكون هذه
الحرب قد اتت بنتائج عكسيه لمكانت تريده
موسكو
في الواقع ان من المهم انني انا يفترض ان
نعيش تحت حكم ديكتاتوريه كما زميلي ولكنني
انتقد رئيسي في حين انه هو يتفق مع كل ما
قاله السيد بايدن نعود الى الوقائع من حيث
المبدا الاخشى ان السيد انا السيد بادل
يخفو وينام
اذا كان الضيف الاخر قلق على الجمهور
بايتن فان السيد بايدن لديه مشاكل صحيه
بمعزل عن هذه الامور التي تضيع وقتها
المقابله ارجوك جاوبني في الموضوع السياسي
الذي سالتك عنه
وبشكل واضح النسب حقائق مهمه جدا فقط قال
بانه هدد بوتين بان فنلندا ستنضم الى
الناتو اذا ما تتسم بوتين بالعدائيه ومن
ثم انه استغرب النفوس استغرب ان السويد
ايضا قررت تنضم الى وهذا يثبت بين السيد
بابل لا يعرف ما هي المعلومات المتوفر
للجمهور كله فكل فنلندا والسويد
ساهموا في المنارات العسكريه الناتو في
منطقه البلقان منذ سنتين عفوا ثمان سنوات
منذ بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا تلك الحرب
بداها بداتها الحكومه الاوكرانيه عندما
ارسل طائرات ودبابات ضد المنطقه
التي يسكنها غالبيه من الروس اذا
لا يعرف ما الذي يجري في اوكرانيا ولا
يعرف ما الذي يجري حول فيما يتعلق بروسيا
واوكرانيا خلال 8 سنوات لكن اللي جاب على
سالك الاجابه على سؤالك لا اعتقد ان
اعمالها وما قالها قام به بوتين اتت من
نتائج عكسيه فان فنلندا والسويد اصبحوا
اعضاء في النيتوك امر واقعي من الزمن طويل
اقراي نشاط الاخبار والجرائد
في بولندا بالملهم ولكن عمليا هذا الذي
وعد به الاستمرار في الدعم الثابت والراسخ
لاوكرانيا وتسليح اوكرانيا وتوسيع النيتو
عمليا هي وعود نفسها منذ عام ولم يتغير
شيء على الارض ولم تستطع اوكرانيا ان تحسم
بعد هذه المعركه ما الذي سيتغير
لديه
عضوان جديده
ارادت الانضمام بسبب العدوان الروسي الغرب
اكثر قوه واتحاضا بسبب العدوان الروسي
ونرى موقفا موحدا بينما نرى اختلافا في
موسكو بين غراسيما
الزعيم
على المدى البعيد هذا البلد العظيم روسيا
الاتحاديه ستمضي اكثر فاكثر الى الظلام
لان هذا الغزو اضعفها واضعف قوتها
العسكريه وكل من اراد او اعتقد ان هذه
الحرب ستكون نصرا سريعا عليه ان يعيد
النظر في حساباته الاوكرانيين دافعوا عن
انفسهم وبلدهم وهذا سوف يستمر شكرا لك
دبلوماسيه الامريكي السابق ومدير وشؤون
روسيا والاستقرار الاستراتيجي في معهد
الولايات المتحده للسلالما واشنطن وشكرا
للسيد متري با بيتش الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ضيفنا من موسكو
وبالحديث عن معاهده التي اعلن الرئيس
الروسي مشاركه بلاده فيها قال المتحدث
الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه سامويل
ان قرار موسكو خطوه غير مسؤوله اضاف في
حديث للجزيره انها تمثل خطوره على العالم
هذه الخطوه كما سمعنا من وزير بلينكن خطوه
مؤسفه وغير مسؤوله لان ليس اي تحديد
للولايه المتحده لدينا الامكانيه للدفاع
عن النفس نحن سناخذ كل الاجراءات اللازمه
لدفع ان الناس بالنسبه هذه هي التحديات
تهديدات الجديده من روسيا حول الاسلحه
النوويه ولكن هي فعلا تمثل خطوره وتماثل
تهديدات للعالم ليس هناك اي دوله التي
تريد ان ترى اي حرب نوويه بين الروسيه
وايضا اخرى اذا نحن نرى ان هذه الخطاب
والكلمات والخطوات من الجانب الروسي فعلا
المؤسفه وغير مسؤوله
هذا وحذرت الامم المتحده من تداعيات اعلان
بوتين بشان معاهده ستارت حيث قالت ان
العالم دون ضبط للاسلحه النوويه هو عالم
اكثر خطوره وغير مستقر مع عواقب وخيمه
محتمله ودعا المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده ستيفاندو
الى الاستئناف الكامل لتنفيذ معاهده
دون تاخير
على الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الروسي
استئناف التنفيذ الكامل لمعاهده ستارتي
الجديده دون تاخير لقد وفرت ستارتو
الجديده والمعاهدات الثنائيه المتعاقبه
بشان خفض الاسلحه النوويه الاستراتيجيه
بين البلدين الامن ليس فقط لروسيا او
الولايات المتحده ولكن المجتمع الدولي
باسره علينا القول ان عالما لا يوجد فيه
ضبط للاسلحه النوويه هو عالم اكثر خطوره
وغير مستقر مع عواقب وخيمه محتمله وينبغي
بدء كل جهد للتجنب هذه النتيجه بما في ذلك
العوده الفوريه للحوار
معاهده ستارت ما الذي تتضمنه وما هي
الظروف التي جاءت بها لنتعرف على الاجابه
في التقرير التالي
عقيده الردع النووي لا تزال قائمه في
سياسات الامنيه لجميع الدول التي لديها
اسلحه نوويه والعديد من حلفائها تقول
الامم المتحده يوجد ثلاثه عشر الفا و مئه
سلاح نووي في العالم وبالرغم من وقوع خفض
كبير في الاسلحه النوويه التي نشرت في
الحرب البارده فانه لم يدمر فعليا حتى راس
النووي واحد
تعد اهم معاهده تحقق التوازن الاستراتيجي
بين القوتين النوويتين الرئيسيتين في
العالم روسيا والولايات المتحده تنص
المعاهده على تخفيض الحد الاقصى للرؤوس
الحربيه الهجوميه الاستراتيجيه للبلدين
بنسبه الثلاثين في المئه ولاليات الاطلاق
الاستراتيجي بنسبه 50 في المئه
[موسيقى]
كما تنص على ان يخفض الطرفان ترسانتهما
النوويه خلال السبع سنوات الى 700 صاروخ
باليسي عابر للقارات وهذا النوع من
الصواريخ قادر على حمل رؤوس الحربيه
كالقنابل او المتفجرات او الرؤوس النوويه
ويتحرك في مسار على شكل قوس من نقطه الى
اخرى
حاولت روسيا في عام 2020 اقناع اداره
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بالدخول في مفاورات لتمديد المعاهده او
اعداد صيغه اخرى جديده لها اصرار واشنطن
على ادراج الصين في المفاوضات لتكون جزءا
من معاهده جديده شكل عائقا امام التوصل
الى اي قرار من النقاط الخلافيه الاخرى
اعتراض واشنطن على تطوير روسيا صواريخ
متطوره تفوق سرعتها تسع مرات سرعه الصوت
وهذا النوع من الصواريخ الباريسيه هو
الاكثر تطورا في العالم ويعتمد على
التحليق في الطبقات العليا من الغلاف
الجوي اعلى من الصواريخ الباليستيه
التقليديه ثم ينفصل عنها الراس الحربي
بسرعه هائله نحو مستويات ادنى الى الاهداف
المحدده في عام
دمرت قنبلتان نوويت
مدينتي هيروشيما ونكزك اليابانيتين
وتشير التقديرات الى قتلهما على الفور ما
مجموعه
213 الف شخص وبعد مرور اكثر من 75 عاما
على هذه الكارثه النوويه اتفقت القوتان
نوويتان رئيسيتان في العالم روسيا
والولايات المتحده على تمديد معاهده
السارت 3 لخمس سنوات اخرى دون ادراج اي
تعديل عليها
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان التصريحات
بشان نقص الذخيره لدى القوات المتطوعه غير
صحيحه على الاطلاق اضافت ان جميع طلبات
الذخيره للوحدات الهجوميه ستقدم في الايام
المقبله جاء ذلك بعد ان اتهم بريجوجن مؤسس
فاجنر كلا من وزيري الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
الروسيين بحرمان مقاتليه من الذخيره
ومحاوله تدمير فاغنر معتبرا ان تلك افعالا
تعادل الخيانه وقال ان ذلك تسبب في خسائر
متزايده بين صفوف فاجنر في المعارك حول
بخموت وفي تسجيل صوتي اشتكاك من ان
مسؤولين لم يكشف عن اسمائهم كانوا يحرمون
مقاتلي فاجنر من امداداتهم بسبب العداء
الشخصي له
يصدر رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه
ووزير الدفاع سيرجي شويجو امرا بعد اخر
بمنع تقديم الذخيره لشركه فاجنر العسكريه
الخاصه
ومساعدتها في النقل الجوي وصلتني معلومات
للتو تفيد بانهم رفضوا طلبا لنا للحصول
على الات للحفر
توصف فاقنر بشركه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
لكنها متهمه بانها الغطاء الذي تمارس من
خلال روسيا نفوذها في مناطق نزاع عديده
ليس اخرها اوكرانيا التقرير التالي يعرف
بهذه الشركه
[موسيقى]
بانها شركه عسكريه خاصه ويراها اخرون اقرب
ما تكون الى مجموعه روسيه عسكريه شبه
رسميه فهي وحده تتمتع وفق صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز بالاستقلاليه وتتبع وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يعتقد ان مؤسسها هو ديمتري اوتكين
ضابط سابق في القوات الخاصه وحملت اسمه
السري فاغنر لكنها الان مملوكه لرجل
الاعمال
ويعرف باسم الطباخ بوتين لادارته شركه
كونكورد المنظمه لحفلات الاستقبال
بالكرملين وتضم مزيجا من مقاتلين يقدمون
خدماتهم مقابل المال بدات العمل لاول مره
مع ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره القرم في عام 2014
ونفذت هجمات في شرق اوكرانيا يقول مسؤولون
بريطانيون ان عدد مقاتل فاغندر ارتفع من
نحو الف الى ما يقرب من 20000 مقاتل في
اوكرانيا اي نحو عشره في المئه من اجمالي
القوات الروسيه على الارض
افتتح بريكوجين اول مقر لفاجنر في مدينه
سامب بطرسبورغ الروسيه وقال في بيانه مهمه
مركز فاغنر هي توفير بيئه مريحه لتوليد
افكار جديده بغيه تحسين القدره الدفاعيه
لروسيا ففي سوريا انتشرت فاجنر لدعم نظام
السوري منذ 2016 خصوصا حول حقول النفط في
دير الزور وخطفت الاضواء اكثر بعد مقتل
عدد من افرادها في غاره امريكيه عام 2018
وتنشط المجموعه في ليبيا منذ 2016 وتدعم
القوات المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر وكشف تقرير سري للامم المتحده وجود
اكثر من الف من عناصرها لكن التقارير اخرى
تقدرهم بالالاف كما تنتشر ميليشيا فاجنر
في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى لحراسه مناجم
الذهب والالماس وتشير تقارير الى وجود لها
في مدغشقر وموزمبيق والسودان وكان اخر
انتشار لها في مالي بعد انسحاب الق
الفرنسيه من هناك
حديثنا عن فاقنر ستكون له مساحه اوسع
للسؤال عن مدى تاثير هذه الخلافات بين
المؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه ومجموعه بات
ينسب لها الفضل في كثيرا من المعارك بعد
قليل في فقره في المتابعه
اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ في تركيا
ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى 42 الف
من جهه اعلن والي هاتاي ارتفاع عدد ضحايا
الزلزالين اللذين ضربا الولايه مساء امس
الى سته قتلى ونحو ثلاثمئه جريح واخرجت
فرق البحث والانقاذ صباح اليوم جاسمين
ثلاثه مواطنين من تحت الانقاض قضوا خلال
محاولاتهم اخراج اغراض من منزلهم المتضرر
من الزلزال السابق
وكانت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
افادت بان الزلزلين بقوه 6 درجات واربعه
من عشره وخمس درجات وثمانيه من عشره على
مقياس ريختر ضربا مركز منطقتي دفنه
وسمانداغ فيها البلاد مساء امس الاثنين
وشهد مواطنوا مدن عده ينزلون للشوارع خوفا
من تضرر المباني من اثار الزلزلين وقد شعر
سكان عشر دول بين سوريا ولبنان والاردن
وفلسطين بالزلزالين
هذا وشرعت فرق الانقاذ التركيه في تقييم
وضع المباني المتضرره جراء الهزتين
الارضيتين اللتين ضربتا محافظه هاتاي
جنوبي البلاد يوم امس ومنعت فرق الانقاذ
ملاك هذه البنايات من العوده اليها مخافه
انهيارها جراء تصدعات التي اصابتها وعبر
مواطنون عن خشيتهم ام من ان يقود هذا
الوضع الى تاخره عمليه اعاده الاعمار
واطاله امد بقائهم في الخيام
لا جديده في حياه هؤلاء سوى جرعه رعب
اضافيه بعد زلزلين متزامنين نكى جراحا لم
تندم بعد
مضى عليهم اسبوعان تحت هذه الخيام التي
نصبت على عجل وهي عندهم اكثر امانا من اي
سقف بيت
الحمد لله لم نصب باذى لكن الاطفال كانوا
خائفين لدرجه انهم اثروا البقاء في الخارج
على الدخول الى الخيمه
الاطفال كانوا خائفين جدا شعرنا بذعر ذاته
الذي عشناه الاسبوع الماضي لكن الحمد لله
لم يخلف الزلزالان الكثير من القتلى
لكنهما فرض واقعا جديدا يجبر الحكومه وفرق
الانقاذ على اعاده الكثير من الحسابات
فالهزات الجديده تسببت بتهدم عدد لا باس
به من المنازل وستضطر فرق الدفاع المدني
الى اعاده تقييم وضع الابنيه من جديد
حسين كان احدا الذين ينوون اخراج ما تبقى
له من متاع من بيته المتضرر بموجب اذونات
من السلطات لكنها اصبحت ملغاتا بعد
الزلزال الاخير وهو ما سيزيد من مشاق
العائلات المتضرره
ما في اذن حتى بالرافعه ما في زن لان
الوضع مو مستقر يعني تغيرت
يعني كان في ضرر مثلا 50% صار 60% لان
الهزه اجت سته فاصله اربعه اخذت عيلتي على
بورصه لعند اخوتي وجيت اذا قدرت في الي
شنطه بس فيها اوراق وهيني خصوصيات اذا
قدرت
مشكله امري لله يعني
اتت الزلازل على كل ما يملكه المتضررون
وهاهم مع موجه هزات جديده في مواجهه واقع
سيعقد مساعيهم للاستقرار من جديد
وسيطيل امدها
ستظل مشاهد ازاله الركام الحاضر الابرز في
يوميات المناطق المنكوبه وستظل مشاعر
الخوف التي احياها الزلزال محفوره في
وجدان الناس اما ما دمرته الزلازل فقد
وعدت الحكومه بانهاء اعمال الاعمار خلال
عام واحد عمر الحاجه جزيره مدينه دفنه من
ولايتها طاي
من انقره معنا ابراهيم اوزير مدير اداره
الكوارث في الهلال الاحمر التركي مرحبا بك
سيد ابراهيم كيف تتطور اعمالكم على الارض
اليوم هو اليوم السادس عشر بعد الزلزال
الاصلي
وابتداء من نقطه الصفر الهلال الاحمر
التركي كنا نقدم الوجبات الساخنه
والمساعدات النفسيه والاجتماعيه
والمساعدات الاخرى التي يحتاجها الناس في
الضغط حقيقه بمرور الزمن يزداد عدد
الاشخاص الذين يحتاجون للوجبات الساخنه
يزداد اليوم نقدم حوال نختم حوالي اثنين
فاصله خمسه مليون شخص
يوميا وحتى الان قدمنا المساعدات بما
يساوي حوالي 57 مليون وجبه غذائيه في
المناطق المتضرره طبعا ليس فقط في الم
المركوبه لكن ايضا في المناطق التي انتقل
فيها الناس من المناطق المنكوبه الى مناطق
اكثر امانا اي تحديات يضيفها استمرار تحرك
الارض من تحتكم زلزاله زلزلاء امس وايضا
الهزات الارتداديه المستمره
اولا هناك ارقام كبيره والناس
البعض
انا انا شعرت بالزلزلان اول والثالث وكنت
في غازي عنتاب عندما ضرب الزلزال الاول
وبعد ان نتجاوزت المرحله الاولى بدا الناس
يعتادون على
المراحل الاولى وتسبب الخوف فجاءت الزلازل
بحدود سته
مقياس ريختر وغيرها اشعرت الناس بالخوف
لكن الوضع كان اقل تهديدا بعض الناس شعروا
بالرغبه الى عوده الى مبانيهم لكن البعض
خاف من ذلك اما في الزلزالان الاخيرين
خسرنا سته اشخاص هذا هو التحدي الاكبر
الذي نواجهه سيد ابراهيم ما خطه الاستمرار
على المدى الطويل في ظل هذه المتطلبات
الهائله ان فقط على مستوى الوجبات نتحدث
عن ملايين الوجبات كيف كيف تخططون
للاستمرار
هذه عمليه كبيره بالتاكيد بل هائله نحن لا
نتحدث فقط عن اناس يعيشون في
البلاد المؤقته طبعا السكان المتاثرين
كانوا اكثر من ثلاثه عشر مليون شخص وبعض
العاملين من دوائر حكوميه رسميه هم ايضا
يشاركوننا في تقديم الوجبات الساخنه بعض
المقدمه دعم الاجتماعي والنفسي لدينا
مستشفيات ميدانيه متنقله الناس الان
يعيشون في الخيم
والعديد منها قد تم انشاؤها
وعلاوه على كل ذلك
مؤسسه افات مستمره في حملاتها وفي جهودها
وسيبقى الناس في بعض المناطق ثم ينتقلون
الى مناطق اخرى الذين تم نقلهم من المناطق
المنكوبه الى المناطق الامنه هم ايضا
يحتاجون الى مساعدات الملابس الى دعم نفسي
دعم اجتماعي ادويه يحتاجون الى
الهلال الاحمر
مع الاطراف الاخرى مدير وادارات الكوارث
في الهلال الاحمر التركي ابراهيم اوزير
ضيفنا من انقر شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
الاحاطه
وفي شمال غرب سوريا افاد الدفاع المدني
السوري باصابه 190 شخصا جراء زلزالين
الجديدين فيها تاي اضاف ان اغلب الاصابات
وقعت بسبب سقوط حجاره او القفز من الابنيه
المرتفعه والتدافع وانهيار بنائين متصدعين
غير ماهولين ومئذنه مسجد في جنديرس شماليه
حلب الى جانب عدد من الابنيه المتصدعه في
خربه الجوز والحمزيه
وبيت صوفان غربيه ادلب دون اصابات فيها
كما انهارت جدران وشرف منازل في عده مدن
وبلدات في ريفي حلب وادلب
قدرت اللجنه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه لغرب
اسيا الاسكوا التابعه للامم المتحده عدد
المعتمدين على دعم الانساني بشمال سوريا
باكثر من اربعه ملايين شخص وقالت الاسكوا
في تقرير جديده لها الى تسعه ملايين شخص
قد تضرروا في سوريا نتيجه الزلزال وطالب
التقرير الاممي بتسهيل وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه الى جميع انحاء سوريا وزياده
الدعم المقدم
هذا وقالت نائبه مدير قسم العمليات
والمناصره في مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق
شؤون الانسانيه غاده الطاهر مضوي ان نداء
المنظمه الدوليه الانساني للاستجابه
للزلزال في سوريا ممول بنسبه 17% فقط حتى
الان مؤكده ان الوضع الانساني في شمال غرب
سوريا كان صعبا حتى قبل وقوع الزلزال
معنا من ادلب المهندس ساريه البيطار مدير
منظمه هذه حياتي الانسانيه مرحبا بك هل
بدا يختلف اي شيء على صعيد المشهد
الانساني والمساعدات الانسانيه في المناطق
حيث تعملون
بدايه الرحمه للشهداء والشفاء العاجل
للجرحى والمصابين الحيه للمساعدات
الانسانيه اللي دخلت من الامم المتحده ما
زالت خجوله لا ترقى لمستوى امم المتحده
دخلت لهذه المنطقه المنكوبه والمنطقه اللي
اساسا هي ما قبل وقوع الزلزال هي منطقه
بحاجه لمساعدات انسانيه بشكل شهري ما دخلت
المساعدات الانسانيه بشكل يليق باسم الام
المتحده مع الاسف عملنا نحن دائما في
المناطق المنكوبه الان من بقوع زلزال او
المنظمات المحليه تفتقده في هذه المناطق
حتى الان نحن نتحدث بعد سته عشر يوما على
وقوع الزلزال ما الذي هو ما الذي
بمس الحاجه اليه
بامثل حاجه لمخيمات لماوى مؤقت يعني الناس
ما عده مؤمنه لانه تقعد تحت اسقف المباني
بالذات هاي المباني اكل التصدعات في مباني
اكل التشققات
الناس كلها خايفه الناس كلها مذهوله
مرعوبه الناس بحاجه انا الان كمستوى مؤسسه
انسانيه الاف الاتصالات يطلبون الخيم
يطلبون السلل الانسانيه يطلبون السلل
الفرشات والحرامات والبطانيات اللي هي
المؤقته
للان الدعم الدولي لهاي لهاي المنطقه ما
زال خجولا ما زال في حاجه ماسه للخيم
والمؤقت لهاي الناس الناس اغلبيتها قاعده
بالمرافق العامه هلا نحن الان في مدينه
ادلب الناس قاعده كلها على الكورنيش
بسياراتها واللي ما عنده سياره قاعد عند
اصدقاء او عند معارف او عند اقارب مع
الاسف مع الاسف لحد الان لم يتم دخول
المساعدات الانسانيه بشكل يكفي لكل
المحتاجين في هاي المناطق المنكوبه مناطق
مدمره بشكل نسبه اكثر بالميه سلقين ماذا
عن المستلزمات الغذائيه والادويه في
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
الى تونس حيث اكدت عضو المكتب التنفيذي
لنقابه الصحفيين التونسيين اميره محمد
احاله نقيب الصحفيين التونسيين مهدي
الجلاص للتحقيق في تهم تتعلق بالتحريض على
العصيان والاعتداء على موظف اثناء اداء
مهامه وقال رئيس حزب افاق تونس انه استدعى
للتحقيق بتهمه التحريض على العنف بعد بيان
عبر فيه عن موقفه من الاستفتاء هذا وقال
رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي ان مسؤوله
امام قاضي التحقيق اليوم هو ثمره جديده
لما وصفه بالانقلاب
[تصفيق]
تدافع لا يتوقف بين السلطه الرئيس التونسي
ومعارضيه في احدث صور هذا التدافع يتجدد
خضوع رئيس البرلمان المنحل وزعيم حركه
النهضه للتحقيق هذه المره على خلفيه قضيه
تعرف بتكفير الامنيين ويرى راشد الغنوشي
ان مثوله امام جهات التحقيق على هذا النحو
ثمره للانقلاب وفق وصفه
وجودنا هنا هو ثمر من ثمار الانقلاب
الانقلاب الذي ليس هو ضد النهضه فقط وانما
الوسيطه وكل الاحزاب وكل النقابات وفق
الغنوشي لا تستهدف الرئاسه حركته وحدها
وهو ما استدعى تضامنه مع سائر الكيانات
سياسيه او نقابيه مشيرا بشكل خاص لاتحاد
الشغل لم يتعرض الغنوشي للتوقيف لكن
قياديين بحركته وبغيرها طالتهم حمله
اعتقالات اخذه في الاتساع خلال شهر فبراير
الج فقط اعتقل ثمانيه من السياسيين
والقضاه بعد الغنوشي بساعات احيل الى
التحقيق نقيب الصحفيين التونسيين مهدي
الجلاصي ورئيس حزب افاق فاضل عبد الكافي
ونشطاء اخرون بالمجتمع المدني التونسي
باشكال مختلفه استهدف الرئيس قيس سعيد
كيانات مختلفه بالدوله بدءا من البرلمان
مرورا بمجلس القضاء وصولا الى الاتحاد
العام للشغل الذي حاول طويلا لاحتفاظ
بحياده لكن امينه العام اكد قبل يومين الا
حياد امام الدفاع عن الحريات النقابيه
والفرديه والعامه نظمت اتحاد الشغل تظاهره
في صفاقس يوم السبت احتجاجا على الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه وشاركت فيها الامينه العامه
لاتحاد النقابات الاوروبيه استرلينج اعتبر
الرئيس التونسي مشاركه لينش تدخلا في شؤون
البلاد وقرر طردها وهي طيفه على المؤسسه
النقابيه الكبرى في تونس
تصاعدت انتقادات دوليه ضد الرئيس الذي اكد
النهار الثلاثاء خلال استقباله وزير
خارجيته ان سياده تونس فوق اي اعتبار
وانها لن تقبل وفق قوله تدخلا في شؤونها
الداخليه
معلم المدينه سوسه شرق تونس قيصر الصياح
المحامي والباحث في القانون ومن تونس ايضا
معنا السيد احمد الغيلوفي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك سيد قيصر
الصياح يعني ماذا وراء كل هذه الاستدعاءات
القضائيه لطيف واسع من الشخصيات لماذا
بهذه الكثافه ما الذي حصل
شكرا مساء الخير لك ولضيفك لا لم يحصل شيء
ودوله تطبيق القانون بحذافيره وبسلامه
وعندما تتجه الدوله الى تطبيق القانون فان
هذا يعني ان الدوله تتواجد على رقح قانوني
وقضائي بامتياز يعني انا سلطه القانون هي
الاساس في تتبع وملاحقه كل من يخالف
القانون هذا ببساطه ثم ثانيا ما نشهد الان
وما نراه تقريبا وانا هناك حلبه صراع
امتزج فيه السياسي بالقانوني واصبح النقد
السياسي اكثر من القانوني اما انا اعترف
بالقانون
ونقوم بتطبيقه ومن ثبتت ادانات ويودان ومن
بر اي برا كما تنص على ذلك المواثيق
والسكوك والمعادله الدوليه وخاصه الماده
11 من الميثاق العالمي لحقوق الانسان
والذي يعطي لكل شخص البراءه الى ان تثبت
ادانته في محاكمه عاد له منصف واما ان
نخرج عن هذا السياق ونعتبر ان كل هذه
الامور يعني امور خارجه عن السياق وهي
تدخل تحت قائله الاستخدام والقمع الى اخره
يبقى انا احيانا قد تظل القدم وقد توجد
بعض الاخلالات وهذه الاخلالات قد تكون تحت
سلطه القضاء الذي وحده له سلطه تكييفها
ووصفه والجرائم والنيابه العموميه لاكامل
الصلاحيات بماده الهجرات الجزائيه والماده
20 من القانون كل صلاحيات في موافق
الدولية
سيد احمد غي لوفي اذا هي دوله القانون هذا
تطبيق للقانون
وبتشدد ما المشكله
مساء الخير تحيه لكم ولمشاهديكم ولذلك في
ذلك اذا كان ضيفكم يعتقد ان ما يقوم به
الان
قيسكره بان المحكمه الاداريه اصدرت قرارا
بالغاء اقصاء القضاه الذين وقع شطبهم
شطبهم
الا انه لم ينضبط لهذا القرار القضائي
واذا كان ضيفكم يعتقد بان هذا الرجل يطبق
القانون يذكره بانه هو موجود فوق القانون
وهو الذي يعني شطب كل المؤسسات وهو الذي
اغلق مجلس النواب واذا كان ضيفكم يعتقد
بانه يتكلم بلغه القانون فانني اذكره ان
قيس سعيد من على يعني مكتب في وزاره
الداخليه اصدرتها ما هو احكامه في نفس
الوقت واشار قال بان هؤلاء الذين سيقع
يعني القبض عليهم مجرمون وارهابيرون
ويخططون للاغتيال هكذا بعظمه لسانه وعندما
قارن الساده المحامون ملفات
المتهمين لم يجدوا اي علاقه بين الاتهام
وما هو موجود في الملفات يعني تهم زائفه
ومضحكه حتى ان بعض القضاه قال اليوم
بشهاده احد المحامين الذين حرروا الجلسه
التي حكم فيها صاحب اذاعه مو قال بانه ليس
هناك تهم يعني والا ان القرار السياسي كان
قبل التهمه وقبل القضاء
هذا هذا ما يقوله معظم محاما مثل امام
القضاء خلال الايام الماضيه واستدعو
للتحقيق بعضهم لم يكن يعلم انه مستدعى
للتحقيق الا صدفه ان هناك استهداف لنشاطاء
في المجتمع المدني لسياسيين من المعارضين
للرئيس التونسي من اجل تصفيه حسابات
سياسيه بتهم ملفقه لا ترقى الى ما يحدث
الى الى الاستدعاءات التي تتم وتعم التي
توجه
اذا جيد اذا جيد واعتبر ان هذا جيد جدا
لاننا في سياق قانوني صرف اذا كانت كل هذه
التوام مضحكه وهذه التوام لا اساس لها من
الصحه فلنترك القضاء الذي له كامل
الاستقلاليه والحياد ليقوم بواجبه ويبرى
من يبرئين ونحن نذكر مره اخرى ان السلطان
القضاء في كل دول العالم
هذه الاستدعاءات على هذا الشكل تؤدي الى
تخويف الى تحذير كل من هو معارض للرئيس
التونسي
ليس صحيح ليس هناك تحذير لان المساله كما
قلت مثلا قانونيه صرفه تحت اشراف القضاء
تحت اشراف المجلس الاعلى للقضاء الذي هو
الوحيد نظام الاستقلاليه القضاء وتحت
اشراف المواد التي نص عليها الميثاق
العربي لحقوق الانسان
وتوصيات الامم المتحده التي تعطي واؤكد
هنا ان
الامم المتحده تؤكد وانا النيابه العموميه
بكل دول العالم والدول العربيه
القيام بواجبها يتبع الشبهات ان وجدت وان
كان هناك اخلال في هذه الشبهات فهذا امر
لا نريده ولا نحبده ويجب على القضاء ان
يقوم بواجبه في اصلاح تلك الاخلالات
تحرك قضائي مجرد من اي نوايا سياسيه
لست ادري لماذا لا يجيب ضيفكم الكريم على
سؤالي السيد البشير البشير العكرمي وقع
الغاء اقصائه واسترجع لوظيفته بقرار من
محكمه التعقيب فلماذا
ينفذ القانون هذا القرار البشير العكرمي
الى اليوم قاضا وله الحصانه الا انه قد
عبس بحالته الصحيه والاجتماعيه وقذف به في
مستشفى الامراض النفسيه والعصبيه لماذا لا
يطبق هذا القانون طالما ان الرجل بقرار
قضائي من اعلى هيئه قضائيه محكمه التعقيم
ارجع لوظيفته لماذا نراوغ كل هذه المراوغه
كل ما يحدث هو كان مخططا له من قيس سعيد
يجب ضرب القضاء وترهيبه وحتى زملائك
المحامين 14 المحامي احيله
سيد احمد ما الهدف من وراء هذه
الاستدعاءات كما تقراها
انه يعد كل الجسم القضائي ينخرط معه في
فبركه واختلاق الملفات حتى يقضي على كل كل
نفس معارض له اعلاميين وسياسيين ونقابيين
ونشطاء وصحافيين حتى لا يقول احد كلمه لا
اذا ما فرغت الاصلاحات الكريهه جدا على
الشعب التونسي هؤلاء الذين الاقليه التي
ما زالت تدافع على ما يسمى المسار التصحيح
لقيس سعيد سوف يكتشفون انفسهم يوما انهم
يدافعون على حفره وهو سحيقه
يسقط فيها الشعب التونسي يكفي يجب ان نعود
للعقل وان نحكم
الضمير على الاقل من الرجال القانون لا
يجب ان ننخرط في هذه اللعبه السيئه جدا
والخطيره على الشعب التونسي ليس هناك
علاقه البته بين التهم وبين الملفات كما
اطلع عليها زملائك يا سيدي المحامي الكريم
يجب ان تكون احمد الغيث
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وشكرا للسيد قيصر
الصياح المحامي والباحث في القانون ضيوفنا
من تونس
[موسيقى]
نعود الى الحديث عن فاجنر الروسيه التي
تلعب دورا يزداد فعاليه في الحرب في
اوكرانيا حيث ظهرت ميليشيا فاجنر كابرز
المجموعات المقاتله الى جانب الجيش الروسي
في اوكرانيا لكن فاجنر على اهميتها ودورها
الرئيسي لم تكن وحيده في الحرب
من مكاتبها الزجاجيه الهادئه في سان
بطرسبرج غربيه روسيا تدير شركه فاجنر احدى
اكبر الميليشيات المقاتله في اوكرانيا
تصر فاغنر على انها شركه عسكريه خاصه الا
انها جزء مهم وفعال من النسيج العسكري
الروسي
ده اشهر قليله من الحرب يظهر قائد فاجنر
مع بعض من جنوده صفقه بين رئيس الشركه
وسجناء جنائيين روس القتال في الجبهه
الاماميه لسته اشهر مقابل العفو والعوده
للحياه الطبيعيه هكذا يدير الرجل المقرب
من بوتين المجموعات المقاتله في اوكرانيا
ظهرت للمره الاولى في قتال عام 2014 قاتلت
في سوريا وليبيا واماكن اخرى لحمايه مناجم
الذهب ضمن صفقات الروسيه مع تلك الدول نفت
روسيا وجود فاغنر في اوكرانيا كما نفت اي
صله بينهما يقول مسؤولون بريطانيون ان عدد
مقاتلي فاجنر ارتفع من نحو الف الى ما
يقرب من عشرين الف مقاتل في اوكرانيا اي
قرابه عشره في المئه من اجمالي القوات
الروسيه على الارض برزت قدرات مقاتل فاجنر
في معارك السوليدار
في ظل انتكاسات الميدانيه للجيش الروسي في
الاشهر الاخيره
ظهر رئيس الشركه مع مقاتله في سوليدار ان
قوته سيطرت على المدينه الاستراتيجيه
بوروسيا عصفورين بحجر تنفذ المهام التي
توصف بالقذره في قتال المدن دون ان تتحمل
تكلفه الخسائر هذا الدور دفع الولايات
المتحده لتصنيف فاجنان منظمه اجراميه
دوليه رد مالكها برساله ساخره مواجهه
للمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
يساله عن الجرائم التي ارتكبتها فاجنر
مقاتلون فاجنر ليسوا وحدهم الغرباء في
الحرب يقاتل الرئيس الشيشاني كذلك الى
جانب القوات الروسيه هناك يرسل رمضان
قديروف الاف المقاتلين من الشيشان الى
اوكرانيا هناك شيشانيون اخر ونقاتلون الى
جانب القوات الاوكرانيه خلاف شيشاني داخلي
يتحول الى صراع بين قاديروف وكتائب الشيخ
منصور الشيشاني هكذا تستعين كل من روسيا
واوكرانيا بمقاتلين اجانب لحسم الصراع
ويستعين المقاتلون الاجانب بكل من روسيا
واوكرانيا لتحقيق مصالح اما السياسيه او
اقتصاديه كل ذلك في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا المستمره منذ عام
معنى
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ومؤلف كتاب
المرتزقه والحرب فهم جيوش الخاصه مرحبا بك
سيد
باعتقادك لماذا وقع الخلاف
في الواقع ان هذا الخصام هو قديم بقدم
المرتزقه والجنود سبب شاهدتنا ذلك هو ان
الجنود
هم كالزوجات والمرتزقه كالعاهرات
وهم فقط يستفيدنا ماليا من الحب ولو نظرنا
الى التاريخ لطالما نشاهدنا ان هناك فرسان
من جانب
ومرتزقه يكرهون بعضهم الاخر ولكن عندما
يذهبون الحرب مارس سويه فان غالبا ما كان
يقتلنا بعضهم الاخر لان كل واحد من يعتبر
اهانه للمعركه التي يدخلون بها
بعيدا عن هذه المقارنات سيد شون اليوم نحن
نرى ان قوات فاجنر تحقق تقدما لصالح روسيا
على الارض في اوكرانيا في جبهات
استراتيجيه ومهمه مثلا كجبهه بخبوت
بالتالي لماذا تقوم وزاره الدفاع بحرمانها
من العتاد والسلاح كما يتهمها
نعم هذا هو سببه ان مجموعه
احرجت الجيش قيادات الجيش والاستغراب
باستخبارات في روسيا فيكي
فاحرجتهم فقط اخذوا منطقه
وهذا كانت اول نصر روسي كبير منذ اشهر وفي
من حيث المبدا في نزار الدفاع روسيا اصدرت
بيانا قالت فيه ان القوات الروسيه التي
سيطرت على ثم صحح تصليح القلب كانت
وبالتالي هناك اذا منافسه موجوده بين
الجيش الروسي والمرتزقه
الذي يمتلك هذه المجموعه
طالما ازدادت انتقاد ذاته الى ما يسميه
في الكرملين وبالتالي هناك منافسه بين
الطرفين باعتقادك اين بوتين من هذا الخلاف
ومعروف ان بريجوجن هو مقرب جدا من الروسي
موقف بوتين هو انه ينضم ويؤيد ان اي طرف
يحقق له الانتصارات وبذل هذه الحالات تكون
مجموعه
فمثلا كان هنا مؤخرا برنامج او قانون في
روسيا يعطي فوائد لابناء الجنود القتلى
وقد واكد على ذلك يمتد وينطبق على مرتزقهر
ولكن لكن اذا ما بداوا يخسرون في المعارك
فاعتقد انه انه تفضيله سينتقل الى الجيش
الروسي لكن هل يستطيع ان ينحاز الى فاقنر
الى هذه الدرجه بعد هذه الانتقادات
اللازعه التي وجهها بريجوجن لي وزير
الدفاع ورئيس الاركان كيف سينعكس ذلك على
علاقه بوتين بوزير دفاعه ورئيس الاركان في
هذه المرحله
الذي اليوم الذي استولت فيه على مدينه
سولدار جرى
اقاله الجنرال كان مسؤولا هناك وكان اكبر
ووضعوا بدله جنرالا اخرا واعتقد واذا ما
ابتعا ابعدهم بوت واحدا بعد الاخر فهو ليس
بالديكتاتور او الحاكم المستبد ولكنه يفعل
ذلك اعتقد انه لا ينحاز الى اجهه بينما
يستفيد من الطرفين ويحرض بعضهما على الاخر
بخدام كل ذلك ماذا عن القوات الشيشانيه
التي ايضا اثبتت فعاليه بالنسبه للتقدم
الروسي
الشيشانيه كانت فعاله جدا وانا زعيمهم
تحدث عن
شركه خاصه به على غرار فوق نار تكون مسلمه
تكون مثل روك نار وتنافسها ولكن ايضا
ستتنافس مع الجيش الروسي ونعرف اذا كان
سيقبل بوتين بذلك اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
واشنطن
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ومؤلف كتاب
المرتزقه والحرب فهم الجيوش الخاصه
راس الساعه مشاهدينا الكرام وهذا تذكير
باهم العنب
عشيه دخولها عامها الثاني الحرب في
اوكرانيا بين خطابين من ورسو بايدن يتحدث
عن جبهه موحده
وتماسك في موقف الدعم لكياف ومن موسكو
بوتين يتهم الغرب بخوض حرب ضد بلاده ويعلق
المشاركه في معاهده الحد من الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه واشنطن تصفها بالخطوه
المؤسفه والامم المتحده تقول ان العالم
دون تدبير السيطره على الاسلحه النوويه
بات اكثر خطوره
على الرغم من تصدر الميليشيا المشهد
الميداني بوادر خلاف وانقسام تطفو على سطح
العلاقه بين فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه
مؤسس المجموعه يتهم وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان الروسيين بالخيانه العظمى ويقول
انهما اصدر اوامر لعدم تزويد مقاتلهم
الذخيره والدفاع الروسيه تقول ان الحديث
عن نقص ذخيره القوات المتطوعه غير صحيح
تركيا وسوريا على وقع مشهد الزلزال
المتكرر اداره الكوارث والطوارئ في انقره
تقول ان عدد قتل الزلزال تجاوز
42,300 وبعد رصد نحو تسعه ملايين سوري
متضرر من الكارثه مسؤوله امميه تقول ان
النداء الاممي للاستجابه للكارثه في سوريا
ممول بنسبه لا تتجاوز 17%
مع تزايد الجدل بشان حمله الايقافات في
تونس نقابه الصحفيين تقول ان نقيب
الصحفيين وناشطين استدعوا للتحقيق على
خلفيه مشاركتهم في احتجاج ضد الاستفتاء
على الدستور في يوليو الماضي وبعد مثوله
للتحقيق مجددا الغنوشي يقول ان الانقلاب
يستهدف كل الكيانات الوطنيه وسعيد يؤكد ان
تونس لن تقبل التدخل الخارجي
قبل يومين من دخول حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
عامها الثاني اعلن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين تعليق مشاركه بلاده بمعاهده ستارت
للحد من الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه بوتين الحق
القرار بامر الى وزاره الدفاع بالاستعدادي
لاختبار الاسلحه النوويه اذا بدات
الولايات المتحده بذلك ومن بولندا اعرب
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عما سماه التزام
بلاده الثابت تجاه اوكرانيا وسيادتها وقال
ان النيتو بات اقوى من اي وقت مضى
والديمقراطيه ستنتصر حتما حسب تعبيره
مبارزه مثيره على المسرح الدولي جعلت
اوكرانيا بين خطابين عشيه الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للحرب من موسكو تحدث الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ومن وارسو الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن خطابان متضادان في كل شيء الا في
تاكيدهما ضمنا ان الحرب مستمره بل هي قد
ترتاد في عامها الثاني مربعات جديده من
التصعيد
وعلى نحو اكثر التعارضا سرد الخطابان
تقييمين مختلفين لعام مضامنا الحرب كان
بالنسبه لبايدن صمودا تاريخيا لكييف
والديمقراطيه الغربيه الراسخه ومن وجهه
نظر بوتين كان عاما حافلا باخفاقات الغرب
في النيل من روسيا واقتصادها
الغرب يستخدم اوكرانيا راس حربه وميدانه
تدريب ضد روسيا ويحاول تغيير سير المعركه
بزياده الامدادات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
وكلما ازداد الامداد بمنظومات الاسلحه
الغربيه لاوكرانيا كلما اضطررنا لابعاد
التهديدات اكثر عن حدودنا
لقد كانت سنه استثنائيه تميزت بوحشيه غير
عاديه من القوات الروسيه والمرتزقه لقد
ارتكبوا جرائم ضد الانسانيه دون خجل او
رافه استهدف المدنيين بالقتل والتدمير
هي مبارزه مشحونه بالرموز والدلالات تذكر
باشد ساعات الحرب البارده توترا خاصه
وانها استحضرت كل عناصر تلك المرحله
الصعبه على اوروبا والعالم
فوارسو عاصمه بولندا التي تحدث منها
الرئيس الامريكي هي نفسها التي كانت ذات
يوم مقر حلفوارسو حلف المنظومه الشرقيه
انذاك في مقابل حلف الناتو المظله
العسكريه للحلفاء هل اراد بوتين اثاره
الغرب اكثر بتعليق اهم اتفاقيه معه ام كان
قراره فعلا لحمايه بلاده
مضطر اليوم للاعلان عن تعليق روسيا
مشاركتها في معاهده تقليص الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه والهجوميه لا ننسحب من
المعاهده بل نعلق مشاركتنا ويجب ان تكون
وزاره الدفاع وشركه الاستعداد لاختبار
الاسلحه النوويه اذا بدات الول المتحده
بذلك
ثم هل تعمد بايدن هذه المره ان يكون في
منطقه الحرب وغير بعيد من موسكو امعانا في
تحديها مسار رحلته من واشنطن الى كيف
ومنها الى وارسو يمكن ان يحيل الى ذلك في
لحظه بدات فيها حرب اوكرانيا اشبه بحرب
امريكيه روسيه راسها بوتين وبايدن وهو ما
قد يجعل وقفها
رهنا بايديهما ايضا
بالحديث عن معاهده ستارت التي اعلن الرئيس
الروسي مشاركه بلاده او تعليق مشاركه
بلاده فيها قال المتحدث الاقليمي باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه سامي ان قرار موسكو
خطوه غير مسؤوله اضاف في حديث الجزيره
انها تمثل خطوره على العالم
هذا وحذرت الامم المتحده من تداعيات اعلان
بوتين بشان معاهده حيث قالت ان العالم دون
ضبط للاسلحه النوويه هو عالم اكثر خطوره
وغير مستقر مع عواقب وخيمه محتمله ودعم
متحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ستيفان دو شاريك واشنطن وموسكو الى
الاستئناف الكامل لتنفيذ المعاهده
معاهده ستارت ما الذي تتضمنه وما هي
الظروف التي جاءت بها لنتعرف على المزيد
في التقرير التالي
عقيده الردع النووي لا تزال قائمه في
سياسات الامنيه لجميع الدول التي لديها
اسلحه نوويه والعديد من حلفائها تقول
الامم المتحده يوجد 13 الفا واربع مئه
سلاح نووي في العالم وبالرغم من وقوع خفض
كبير في الاسلحه النوويه التي نشرت في
الحرب البارده فانه لم يدمر فعليا حتى راس
النووي واحد
الثلاثه تعد اهم معاهده تحقق التوازن
الاستراتيجي بين القوتين النوويتين
الرئيسيتين في العالم روسيا والولايات
المتحده تنص المعاهده على تخفيض الحد
الاقصى للرؤوس الحربيه الهجوميه
الاستراتيجيه للبلدين بنسبه الثلاثين في
المئه ولاليات الاطلاق الاستراتيجي بنسبه
50 في المئه
[موسيقى]
كما تنص على ان يخفض الطرفان ترسانتهم
النوويه خلال السبع سنوات الى 700 صاروخ
باليسي عابر للقارات وهذا النوع من
الصواريخ قادر على حمل رؤوس الحربيه
كالقنابل او المتفجرات او الرؤوس النوويه
ويتحرك في مسار على شكل قوس من نقطه الى
اخرى
اولت روسيا في عام 2020 اقناع اداره
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بالدخول في مفاورات لتمديد المعاهده او
اعداد صيغه اخرى جديده لها اصرار واشنطن
على ادراج الصين في المفاوضات لتكون جزءا
من معاهده جديده شكل عائقا امام التوصل
الى اي قرار من النقاط الخلافيه الاخرى
اعتراض واشنطن على تطوير روسيا صواريخ
متطوره تفوق سرعتها تسع مرات سرعه الصوت
وهذا النوع من الصواريخ الباريسيه هو
الاكثر تطورا في العالم ويعتمد على
التحليق في الطبقات العليا من الغلاف
الجوي اعلى من الصواريخ الباليستيه
التقليديه ثم ينفصل عنها الراس الحربي
بسرعات هائله نحو مستويات ادنى الى
الاهداف المحدده في عام
دمرت قنبلتان نوويتان مدينتي هيروشيما
ونكزك اليابانيتين
وتشير التقديرات الى قتلهما على الفور ما
مجموعه
213 الف شخص وبعد مرور اكثر من 75 عاما
على هذه الكارثه النوويه اتفقت القوتان
نوويتان رئيسيتان في العالم روسيا
والولايات المتحده على تمديد معاهده
السارت ثلاثه لخمس سنوات اخرى دون ادراج
اي تعديل عليها
[موسيقى]
من زوري ينضم الينا هنري كبير الباحثين في
مركز زوريخ لدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
مرحبا بك سيد هنج
معاهده هي اخر معاهده للسيطره على التسلح
بين اكبر قوتين نوويتين ماذا يعني بالتالي
اعلان موسكو تعليق العمل بها
انها سواقه بشكل كبير خطوه رمزيه لان
اتفاقيه او معاهده
سوف تنتهي مفعوله في 2026 بعد ثلاث سنوات
وبالتالي فان التعليق موجود فعلا ناحيه
العمليه بسبب ازمه كوفيد عندما جرى تعليق
الاعمال التفتيش ولم تستانف لاحقا
وبالتالي ثم يقوله الان هو انه لن يسمح
الان باستئناف عمليات التفتيش على القوات
الاستراتيجيه ايضا هي بشكل كبير اجراء
رمزي وكان لابد يقول شيئا ما في خطابه بعد
سنه من الغزو لماذا اعتبرته رمزيا سيد
هاني هناك من بدا يحذر من عوده سباق
التسلح من زياده الرؤوس النوويه لماذا لا
تعتقد انه يجب ان نخاف من كل ذلك
بالتاكيد لابد ان نشعر القلق ازاء ذلك لكن
في جميع الاحوال التفتيش من الجانبين جرى
تعليقه فليس مهما اذا ما جرى طبقت
المعاهده او لم تطبق رسميه واضافه ذلك فان
هل ان البلدين يحتاجون فقط الى زياده
قواتهم الاستراتيجيه لاغراض الردع خاصه ان
هناك عوامل كثيره غير الردع وليس فقط عدد
الرؤوس الحربيه التي يمكن نشرها لكن الان
يعني ان كان يجب علينا ان نقلق كما قلت
يعني ما هي الخطوه المقبله في ظل هذه
العلاقه المتدهوره جدا بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده
فعلا ان ذلك
يؤثر على استقرار العلاقه بين القوتين
عضميتين طبعا هذه خطوه للوراء لكن هناك
عناصر اخرى
لتدهور العلاقات بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده
وكثير العناصر الاخرى مثل الاستحاء فائقه
السرعه
في سؤالي قصدت في سؤالي ان موضوع تدهور
العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده وموسكو كيف
يمكن ان ينعكس في هذه المرحله على سباق
التسلح والرؤوس النوويه في ظل توقف معاهده
ستارت
التفاح محدود جدا بين روسيا ولايه المتحده
وبسبب تهو العلاقات بينهما وهذه المعاهدات
اصبحت خارج
غير مؤثره وبالتالي الثقه الدبلوماسيه في
انخفاض وبالتالي
الدبلوماسيين ان يثقوا بالعناصر
الاستراتيجيه بينهما هي جيده وان
التاثيرات العمليه بالنسبه للعسكريين
محدود لانهم ليس هناك عمليات تفتيش
شكرا لك
لارسن كبير والباحثين في مركز زوريخ
لدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
على مشارف نهايه العام الاول من الحرب في
اوكرانيا ما زال حديث العقوبات حاضرا في
الغرب للتضييق على روسيا ورغم العزله
المفروضه عليها بعد انسحاب مئات الشركات
وانقطاعها عن النظام المصرفي العالمي
تعافت العمله الوطنيه بعد اسابيع فقط من
بدايه الحرب كما اعادت بعض القطاعات
الاستراتيجيه تفعيل وحدات انتاج جديده
لتعويض النقص الذي افرزته العقوبات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في بردي موسكو لا يستعصي التدثر بادفئ
الملابس واحدث المنسوجات
لكن ما كانت يوما مع عاطفه اسبانيه
وايطاليا غدت الان البسه تجهزها شركات
روسيه حولت ازمه انسحاب شركات عالميه من
روسيا الى فرصه لتعزيز حضورها في اكبر
المراكز التجاريه
سجلنا في حجم المبيعات من مارس الى نهايه
العام الماضي بنسبه 63% هذا يعود الى رحيل
العلامات التجاريه الاجنبيه من السوق
الروسيه وهذا ما شجع الناس على اختيار
مصنعي الملابس الروسيه بحماس
حماسه يبدو انها انتقلت ايضا الى قطاع
صناعه السيارات في وحدات الانتاج التي
كانت ملكا لشركه رونو الفرنسيه ينتج
العمال انفسهم سياره خال الروس ان بريقها
خفت بعد انتهاء الحقبه السوفياتيه اما وقد
غادرت معظم الشركات الغربيه والكوريه
الجنوبيه فان هدف موسكو الان هو انتاج 800
الف وحده خلال العام الجاري
اطلق المصنع سياره جديده خلال سته اشهر
فقط وهذا انجاز عالمي والاهم من ذلك كان
قرار الاحتفاظ بعمال الشركه السابقه الذين
حققوا انتاجا جيدا
مثل هذه القرارات ساهمت في خفض مستويات
البطاله الى ثلاثه وسبعه اعشار في المئه
بحسب موسكو التي تضيف هذا الانجاز الى
نجاحات اخرى يبقى ابرزها تعافي الروبل
امام الدولار تعافي لا يزيح كل التحديات
التي قد تواجه الاقتصاد الروسي على المدى
البعيد فحظر 90% من النفط الروسي في
الاتحاد الاوروبي قد يحرم موسكو من عائدات
تبلغ 22 مليار دولار لكن لخبراء الاقتصاد
الروسي راي اخر
واضح ان موارد الطاقه والمعادن والاسمده
الروسيه الضروريه في الاقتصاد العالمي من
يعتقد ان فرض مثل هذه العقوبات سيكون
فعالا هو بكل بساطه مخطئ
العقوبات مثل السم بطيئه المفعول لكنها
تتسبب حتما في اثار لا رجعه هكذا وصف ممثل
سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
العقوبات الاقتصاديه المفروضه على روسيا
لكن هذا القول يصطدم الان بتوقعات ترى ان
الاقتصاد الروسي سيعود الى سكه النمو
معتمدا على موارد روسيا الطبيعيه وعلى
اسواق الهند والصين وتركيا التي خففت من
حده العقوبات الغربيه ايمن الزبير الجزيره
موسكو
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من لندن نهاد
اسماعيل الخبير في الشؤون الاقتصاديه
مرحبا بك سيد نهاد عقوبات كثيره واليوم
الرئيس الامريكي يعد بالمزيد من العقوبات
على موسكو اين نجحت واين اخفقت
للمشاهدين الكرام وشكرا على الاستضافه
الاقتصاد الروسي لا يزال مرن
وتحمل العقوبات ولكن الخساره محدوده حتى
الان اعترف اعترفت وزاره الماليه بخصائب
نقص 46% او عجز في الميزانيه لشهر يناير
ما يعادل 17 مليار دولار لكن العقوبات
الاوروبيه معظمها اثر تاثيرا كبيرا على
الاقتصاد الروسي خاصه انسحاب الشركات
الكبرى من روسيا حوالي 500 شركه تركت
روسيا
وبعضها قلص نشاطها وبعضها باع حصته لشركات
روسيه التاثير على روسيا طبعا سيكون كبيرا
ولكن لن يغير مسار الحرب ولن يثنيروا
روسيا عن اهدافها لذلك هذه العقوبات هي
فقط لمعاقبه روسيا وخذي عقوبه كمثل بسيط
اعطيك اياه قالوا ان اسعار لما عندما
فرضوا الحظر على النفط الروسي اعتبار من
خمسه ديسمبر الماضي ووضعوا سقف 60 دولار
اصرت الولايات المتحده ان العقوبات يجب ان
لا تمنع تدفق النفط الروسي للاسواق لذلك
يعني وضعوا اليه
لاستمرار روسيا في بيع النفط ولكن هناك
ضغوط كبيره على قطاع الطاقه الروسيه يعني
بتفاوت كما ذكرت والاعتماد الان من جانب
روسيا هو على
اسواق الهند والصين بالدرجه الاولى
لا لا يكفي لانه اقول لك ان روسيا والهند
تشتري الغاز والنفط الروسي بخصم كبير
وروسيا تريد الحفاظ على هذا السوق المهم
الاسيوي ولكنها خسرت اكبر السوق واكبر
مستورد للنفطر الروسي كانت تستورد خمس
اوروبا تستورد 25% من حاجتها من النفط
45% من حاجتها من الفحم الحجري واربعين في
المائه من حاجتها من الغاز هذا قيمته تزيد
عن 250 مليار دولار سنويا هذا السوق فقد
لان اوروبا حسمت امرها الان ولا تريد ان
تشتري الطاقه من روسيا بل من مصادر اخرى
وجدت مصادر بديله مثلا الغاز الطبيعي
المسالم من الولايات المتحده من قطر من از
من الجزائر
هي المدى الاكبر هي الخاسر لكن الان
التعفير يعتبر محدود لان روسيا لم توقف
اله الحرب ولا تزال الحرب قائما هناك حاله
عدم نعم يعني كما يقال العقوبات هي سيف ذو
حدين ماذا عن الحد الذي اصاب اوروبا
نعم نعم هذا هذا سؤال مهم جدا اوروبا عانت
اوروبا اوروبا خسرت مئات المليارات من
اليوروات
لاستيراد الطاقه من الخارج لان الشحن من
الولايات المتحده ومن الشرق الاوسط ومن
قطر ومن عزربيجان والجزائر يكلف اكثر لان
الغاز كان ياتي الغاز الطبيعي من خلال
انابيب من روسيا القريبه على الحدود
الاوروبيه لذلك هناك خساره والان اوروبا
حسب وكاله الطاقه الدوليه يجب ان ترصد
تريليون دولار للطاقه المتجدده البديله
والهيدروجينيه والرياح والشمس وغير ذلك
وايضا الان تدفع ثمنا باهظا للنفط لذلك
الكل يخسر لا يوجد رابح في هذه الحرب وفي
هذه
المواجهه بين الغرب والشرق
الخبير في الشؤون الاقتصاديه ضيفنا من
لندن
في اوكرانيا مشهد الاوضاع المعيشيه اكثر
تعقيدا حيث تاثرت انماط عيش الاوكرانيين
بشكل كبير وبدلت ضراوه المعارك وتدمير
المباني السكنيه والبنى التحتيه لا سيما
منشات الطاقه حياه السكان بشكل جذري
مراسله الجزيره كاترين حنا استطلعت احوال
سكان كييف ومحيطها مع دخول الحرب على
بلادهم عمها الثاني
يدير مكسيم هذا المطعم في كييف
لكن قلبه وفكره في المانيا
الى هناك لجات زوجته انيه وابنه ايفان قبل
اشهر
بعد 25 عاما من الزواج نعيش بعيدين
ونتواصل مع بعضنا عن بعد هذا ما فرضته
علينا الحرب نحاول السيطره على حياتنا
العائليه
قات الحرب ملايين الاوكرانيين ودمرت
بيوتهم كثيرون تحولوا الى لاجئين في اسقاع
العالم او نازحين في مراكز ايواء
لكن اخرين كانيكولاي قرروا البقاء وها هو
يحاول ترميم منزله بعد عشره اشهر على
تدميره
هذا المنزل كان سليما لكن سقطت عليه
قذفتان تعالوا لاريكم هنا سقطت قذيفه وهنا
ايضا الان استبدلنا النوافذ هذه نوافذ
جديده وهنا العمال يقومون بما يلزم نحاول
ان نصلح بقدر الدعم الذي يقدم لنا
لكن الدعم مهما بلغ فلا يعيد الحياه هنا
الى ما كانت عليه قبل الحرب مشهد كهذا لم
يعد غريبا فلا مياها ولا كهرباء في
المنازل بعدما تضررت منشات الطاقه والبنى
التحتيه بالقصف الروسي
يصعب علي الانتظار من اجل تعبئه المياه لا
سيما عندما يكون هناك ازدحام كبير قبل
الحرب كانت المياه لا تنقطع في منازلنا
اما الان فلا
وخيمه الصمود هذه كما يسميها الاوكرانيون
تجد مثلها في مختلف ارجاء العاصمه
يقصدونها خلال ساعات التقنين بالتيار
الكهربائي فينعمون هنا بالدفء والطاقه
تقطع الكهرباء الان وفق مواعيد واحيانا
تقطع اربع ساعات متتاليه اتي الى هنا
لانني طالب جامعي وعلي متابعه المحاضرات
وانجاز فروض والان انا بانتظار ان يتمكن
الاستاذ من الاتصال بنا
هكذا تبدلت احوال الاوكرانيين بعد عام على
الحرب تبدل نرى جانبا منه في وجوههم لكن
اثره الاكبر يبقى في النفوس مع دخول الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا عامها الثاني لا
يلوح في الافق امل بنهايه قريبه لمعاناه
الاوكرانيين فالحرب لم تضع اوزارها بعد لا
بل تكون السلطات الاوكرانيه ان الاشهر
المقبله ستشهد هجمات روسيه اضافيه ما قد
يوسع نطاق المعارك ويطيل من امدها كاترين
حنا الجزيره كييف
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان التصريحات
بشان نقص الذخيره لدى القوات المتطوعه غير
صحيحه على الاطلاق اضافت ان جميع طلبات
الذخيره للوحدات الهجوميه ستقدم في الايام
المقبله جاء ذلك بعد ان اتهم بريغوجين
مؤسس فاجنر كلا من وزيري الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان الروسيين بحرمان مقاتليه من
الذخيره ومحاوله تدمير فاغنر معتبرا ان
تلك افعالا تعادل الخيانه وقال ان ذلك
تسبب في خسائر متزايده في صفوف فاجنر في
المعارك حول باخبوت وفي تسجيل صوتي اشتكى
من ان مسؤولين لم يكشف عن اسمائهم كانوا
يحرمون مقاتلي فاجنر من امداداتهم بسبب
العداء الشخصي له
يصدر رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه فاليري
غراسي موف ووزير الدفاع سيرجي شويجو امرا
بعد اخر بمنع تقديم الذخيره لشركه فاجنر
العسكريه الخاصه
ومساعدتها في النقل الجوي وصلتني معلومات
للتو تفيد بانهم رفضوا طلبا لنا للحصول
على الات للحفر
معنى من موسكو بافلنجهاور الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
كيف وجدت اتهامات بريغوجين
ورد وزاره الدفاع بان الذخيره ستاتي
[موسيقى]
مجموعه فاكنار التي تاسست في
الخمسينات نتيجه عسكريين مسرحين
لاسم الحركه لبذكره
الخاصه
بالتاريخ بعيدا حدثنا عن اللحظه الان
لماذا وصل الخلاف الى هذه النقطه والى هذه
الى هذه الحده
في الواقع ان هذا هذه المجموعه تشكت على
مسرحين من الجيش لم يحبوا الهرمي العسكريه
وان مؤسس هذه المجموعه لكن لديه خلفيه
عسكريه كان بل كان مدانا في ايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي
وكان قليلا من بوتين في ساند بيت في
التسعينيات وكان يقدم الاموال والدعم
السياسي لمجموعه
وهو فعلا لديه برنامج سياسي باستخدامه
لمجموعه فاغنر الذين يحبون العسكر اطلاقا
يحصل على جذه جاذبيه سياسيه في موسكو
ولدى القاده العليا الكبار القاده في
لا تجد انه لا تستغرب ان يعني
تصدر عن يفجان بريجين كل هذه عائلتهامات
بالخيانه العظمى من جانب وزاره لوزاره
الدفاع ولرئيس الاركان في وقت تحقق قوات
فاجنر تقدما على الارض لصالح روسيا
انا لا في الواقع هذه حقيقه بان
بان رئيس الكربلند
ان الرئيس بوتين
لديه مشاكل مع العسكريين وقد غير عده
جرارات في الاشهر الماضيه وان هذا الوضع
يستغله مجموعه الاساءه الى اكبر
رتبتين باقيتين وزير الدفاع ورئيس هيئه
الاركان اليهما
وهو ما يحاولان الرد عليه
وبالتالي فهذا يعتبر نوع من المصادم
السياسيه بينهما وان الرئيس بوتين سمح
ويسمح لهم بهذا الشيء كما في كثير الدول
اثناء صدام حسين بوتين
يحب العسكريه ان يكونوا منقسمين فيما
بينهم لان هذا بالنسبه له
امانا وسلامه اكبر اذا ما كانتخاصمون فيما
بينهم هذا ليس بشيء جيد لكن هو يسمح لهم
بذلك فالجانبان يناشدان بوتين والجمهور
والجانبان لديهم
معركه مفتوحه ويبدو ان بوتين يرى ان هذا
امر جيد فهذا يعني ان بوتين هو صاحب
القرار النهائي والحكم ايضا شكرا لك
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من
موسكو
[موسيقى]
اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ في تركيا
ارتفاع عدد قتلى الزلزال الى
42,00010 من جهه اعلن والي هاتاي ارتفاع
عدد ضحايا زلزلين اللذين ضربا الولايه
مساء امس الى سته قتلى ونحو 300 جريح
واخرجت فرق البحث والانقاذ صباح الامس
جثمين ثلاثه مواطنين من تحت الانقاض قضوا
خلال محاولتهم اخراج اغراض من منزلهم
المتضرري من الزلزال السابق
هذا وشرعت فرق الانقاذ التركيه في تقييم
وضع المباني المتضرره جراء الهزتين
الارضيتين اللتين ضربتا محافظه هاتاي
جنوبيه البلاد يوم امس ومنعت فرق الانقاذ
ملاك هذه البنايات من العوده اليها مخافه
انهيارها جراء التصدعات التي اصابتها وعبر
مواطنون عن خشيتهم من ان يقود هذا الوضع
الى تاخر عمليه اعاده الاعمار واطاله امد
بقائهم في الخيام
لا جديده في حياه هؤلاء سوى جرعه رعب
اضافيه بعد زلزلين متزامنين نكى جراحا لم
تندمي بعد
[موسيقى]
لم يخلف الزلزالان الكثير من القتلى
لكنهما فرض واقعا جديدا يجبر الحكومه وفرق
الانقاذ على اعاده الكثير من الحسابات
فالهزات الجديده تسببت بتهدم عدد لا باس
به من المنازل وستضطر فرق الدفاع المدني
الى اعاده تقييم وضع الابنيه من جديد
حسين كان احدا الذين ينوون اخراج ما تبقى
له من متاع من بيته المتضرر بموجب اذونات
من السلطات لكنها اصبحت ملغاتا بعد
الزلزال الاخير وهو ما سيزيد من مشاق
العائلات المتضرره
ما في اذن حتى بالرافعه ما في زن لان
الوضع مو مستقر
تغيرت
يعني كان في ضرر مثلا 50% صار 60% لان
الهزه اجت سته فاصله اربعه اخذت عيلتي على
بورصه لعنده اخوتي وجيت اذا قدرت في الي
شنطه بس فيها اوراق وهيني خصوصيات اذا
قدرت
مشكله امري لله يعني
اتت الزلازل على كل ما يملكه المتضررون
وهاهم مع موجه هزات الجديده في مواجهه
واقع سيعقد مساعيهم للاستقرار من جديد
وسيطيل امدها
ستظل مشاهد ازاله الركام الحاضر الابرز في
يوميات المناطق المنكوبه وستظل مشاعر
الخوف التي احياها الزلزال محفوره في
وجدان الناس اما ما دمته الزلازل فقد وعدت
الحكومه بانهاء اعمال الاعمار خلال عام
واحد عمر الحاجه الجزيره مدينه دفنه من
ولايتها طاي
وفي شمال غرب سوريا افاد الدفاع المدني
السوري باصابه 190 شخصا جراء زلزالين
الجديدين فيها تاي اضاف ان اغلب الاصابات
وقعت بسبب سقوط حجاره او القفز من الابنيه
المرتفعه والتدافع وانهيار بنائين متصدعين
غير ماهولين ومئذنه مسجد في جنديرس شماليه
حلب
قدرت اللجنه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه لغرب
اسيا الاسكوا التابعه للامم المتحده عدد
المعتمدين على الدعم الانساني بشمال سوريا
باكثر من اربعه ملايين شخص وقالت الاسكوا
في تقرير جديد لها الى تسعه ملايين شخص قد
تضرروا في سوريا نتيجه الزلزال
وقالت نائبه مدير قسم العمليات والمناصره
في مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه غاده الطاهر مضوي ان نداء
المنظمه الدوليه الانساني للاستجابه
للزلزال في سوريا ممول بنسبه 17% فقط حتى
الان
من بيروت معنا الدكتور علي حيدر الاستاذ
الجامعي المتخصص في تحليل واداره الكوارث
الطبيعيه مرحبا بك دكتور علي حيدر لماذا
تكرر الزلزال بالامس في نفس المنطقه
هذا امر طبيعي عندما تحدث زلازل بقوه
معينه بعدها بفتره لا
تنتفي هذه الزلازل نهائيا تبقى ولكن بقوه
اقل وهو فعلا ما حصل وهذه الزلازل يمكن ان
تستمر لاشهر متتاليه طبعا ليست بالقوه
التي شهدناها بزلزلين الاخيرين ولكن
استمرار الزلازل بقوه او بوتيره اكثر
وبقوه اقل هذا اما طبيعي بعد كبيره هذا
الدكتور علي الخبراء كانوا يتحدثون بعد
زلزال الذي ضرب كهرمان مرعش او كان ذلك
مركز وكانوا يتحدثون عن ان الكم الاكبر من
الطاقه خرج من باطن الارض بالامس الزلزلين
فيها تاي اتايى على قوه يعني نسبيا عاليا
على مقياس الاخره هل هناك تفسير لذلك
تاريخيا عندما تحصل زلازل قويه في منطقه
معينه بعد ذلك بفتره تبدا بالمناطق
المجاوره زلازل بقوه اقل وتنتشر هذه
البقعه جغرافيا اكثر واكثر مع زمن هذا امر
احصائي وليس هنالك قوانين بهذا المعنى اذا
توقع ان يكون هنالك زلازل ليس بالمنطقه
ذاتها وانما بالمناطق المجاوره هذا امر
طبيعي وفي كل الاتجاهات حصل زلزال في
ايران يعني الى الشرق من الزلزال التركي
وحصلت وحصل هذين الزلزلين الى الغرب من
الزلزال من منطقه الزلزال التركي الاصليه
اذا الانتشار الجغرافي يحصل وكان هذا يحصل
في مناطق
انتشار جغرافي دكتور علي يعني بلدان كثيره
شعرت بهذا الزلزال بالامس لبنان سوريا
فلسطين الاردن يعني عندما تتحدث عن مناطق
مجاوره ما هو نطاقها
كلما كان اقوى
بالاصل كلما اتسع النطاق الجغرافي اكثر
هذه كلها امور احصائيه وتقريبيه وليس
هنالك قوانين ولكن الانتشار الجغرافي له
معنيان المعنى الاول انه بعد الزلزال
القوي بفتره معينه تاتي زلازل بقوه اقل
وعلى مسافه ابعد في كافه الاتجاهات وخاصه
على الشريط الزلزالي وليس في اي مكان هذا
اول معنى المعنى الثاني انه اذا حصل زلزال
معين يشعر به سكان المناطق المجاوره انا
لا اتكلم عن المعنى الثاني ان اتكلم عن
المعنى الاول
ربما اذا اردنا ان ننظر الى الخريطه
الخريطه تقول ان هذا الشريط الذي حصل عليه
الزلزال الاساس الكبير يمتد من حيث الشرق
باتجاه ايران يعني من جبال تورس الى جبال
زاجروس وانما من حيث الغرب يمتد الى
الجنوب من قبرص ما يرتفع نحو اليونان نحو
ايران لاحظنا ان هنالك هزه خمسه فاصله
ثلاثه وعاده وسائل الاعلام تقول على مقياس
ريختر وهذا غير صحيح لانه
وكاله الهزات الامريكيه تعطي المقياس ليس
على طريقه رختر وربما نشهد في الايام
القليله المقبله انتشار جغرافيا على الى
جهه الغرب ايضا دائما ليس هنالك اي شيء
واضح كان هناك كانت هناك صور اليوم جرت
تداولها عن انحصار للمياه في عدد من المدن
في البحر المتوسط وربط ذلك بموضوع الزلزال
هل من رابط فعلا
يجب ان نسير بمنهجيه بحث علمي لانه ليس
هنالك قياسات بهذا الموضوع تاريخيا هل
صحيح ان المياه كانت تنحسر احيانا بهذا
المقدار صحيح كانت تنحسر طبعا لمن يعيش في
هذه المنطقه او تلك حيث حصل الانحسار لمده
عشر سنوات او 20 سنه ربما لا يتذكر ذلك
ولكن من يعيش على مدى خمسون عاما ربما
يتذكر ان هكذا انحسارات كانت تحصل ولكن
هذه الانحسارات لديها عده احتمالات
للتفسير على المدى القصير كان الاحتمال
الاول هو المد والجزر ولكن عاده المد
والجزر في حوض المتوسط له نظام نصف يومي
اي انه خلال فتره قصيره يرتفع وينزل اكثر
من مره باليوم وهو ما لم يحصل اذا المد
والجزر لا علاقه له الان نذهب الى تفسير
كلون الاثار العكسي وهذا يمكن ان يمتد
لاسابيع واذا كان بعد اسابيع لم تعود
المياه عندها الى الاحتمال الثالث لان لان
زلزال هو السبب ولكن الدكتور علي حيدر
في تحليل واداره الكوارث الطبيعيه اشكرك
جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
اكدت عضو المكتب التنفيذي لنقابه الصحفيين
التونسيين اميره محمد حاله نقيب الصحفيين
التونسيين مهدي الجلاص للتحقيق في تهم
تتعلق بالتحريض على العصيان والاعتداء على
موظف اثناء اداء مهامه وقال رئيس حزب افاق
تونس انه استدعى للتحقيق بتهمه التحريض
على العنف بعد بيان عبر فيه عن موقفه من
الاستفتاء هذا وقال رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي ان مثوله امام قاضي التحقيق اليوم
هو ثمره جديده لما وصفه بالانقلاب
[تصفيق]
تدافع لا يتوقف بين السلطه الرئيس التونسي
ومعارضيه في احدث صور هذا التدافع يتجدد
خضوع رئيس البرلمان المنحل والزعيم حركه
النهضه للتحقيق هذه المره على خلفيه قضيه
تعرف بتكفير الامنيين ويرى راشد الغنوشي
ان مثوله امام جهات التحقيق على هذا النحو
ثمره للانقلاب وفق وصفه
من ثمار الانقلاب
الانقلاب الذي ليس ضد النهضه فقط وانما
وظلت كل الكائنات الوسيطه وكل الاحزاب وكل
النقابات وفق الغنوشي لا تستهدف الرئاسه
حركته وحدها وهو ما استدعى تضامنه مع سائر
الكيانات سياسيه او نقابيه مشيرا بشكل خاص
لاتحاد الشغل لم يتعرض الغنوشي للتوقيف
لكن قياديين بحركته وبغيرها طالتهم حمله
اعتقالات اخذه في الاتساع خلال شهر فبراير
الج فقط اعتقل ثمانيه من السياسيين
والقضاه بعد الغنوشي بساعات احيل الى
التحقيق نقيب الصحفيين التونسيين مهدي
الجلاصي ورئيس حزب افاق فاضل عبد الكافي
ونشطاء اخرون بالمجتمع المدني التونسي
باشكال مختلفه استهدف الرئيس قيس سعيد
كيانات مختلفه بالدوله بدءا من البرلمان
مرورا بمجلس القضاء وصولا الى الاتحاد
العام للشغل الذي حاول طويلا لاحتفاظ
بحياده لكن امينه العام اكد قبل يومين الا
حياد امام الدفاع عن الحريات النقابيه
والفرديه والعامه نظمت اتحاد الشغل تظاهره
في صفاقس يوم السبت احتجاجا على الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه وشاركت فيها الامينه العامه
لاتحاد النقابات الاوروبيه استرلينش اعتبر
الرئيس التونسي مشاركه لينش تدخلا في شؤون
البلاد وقرر طردها وهي ضيفه على المؤسسه
النقابيه الكبرى في تونس
تصاعدت انتقادات دوليه ضد الرئيس الذي اكد
النهار الثلاثاء خلال استقباله وزير
خارجيته ان سياده تونس فوق اي اعتبار
وانها لن تقبل وفق قوله تدخلا في شؤونها
الداخليه
هي اخبارنا الاخرى منعت السلطات
الاسرائيليه النائبه في البرلمان الاوروبي
ان ميراندا من الدخول
عبر تل ابيب الى الضفه الغربيه ضمن زياره
رسميه لوفد من البرلمان الاوروبي وفي
تغريده لها في تويتر قالت ان ميرندا انها
طردت من قبل اسرائيل بعد ساعه من الانتظار
وتم ترحيلها الى مدريد وعلقت رئيسه
الاتحاد الاوروبي روبيرتامتسولا على طرد
ميرندا بالقول انها تشعر بخيبه امل كبيره
وانها ستطلب من السلطات الاسرائيليه
توضيحا وستعرب عن قلق الاتحاد الاوروبي
مما حصل
قالت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان المملكه
وقعت اتفاقيه وديعه مع البنك المركزي
اليمني بمبلغ مليار دولار وقد تم ايداعه
بالكامل لدى حساب البنك
واشارت الى ان الوديعه ستسهم في تعزيز
القدرات في مجال تنفيذ برنامج الاصلاح
الاقتصادي باليمن بالتعاون مع صندوق النقد
العربي كجهه فنيه واكدت ان هذا الدعم ياتي
تاكيدا من المملكه على وقوفها الدائم مع
اليمن حكومه وشعبا ومساعدتها للنهوض
بواجباتها في سبيل استعاده امن واستقرار
اليمن
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني الى تبادل الاسرى بين ايران
والولايات المتحده كان على وشك ان يتم في
اطار المفاوضات بين البلدين واشار الى ان
واشنطن كانت بصدد اتمام صفقه لتبادل
السجناء الا انها لم تفي بالتزاماتها وفق
قوله
واشاد كنعان بدوري دوله قطر الايجابي فيما
يخص مفاوضات تبادل السجناء غير المباشر مع
واشنطن وثمنا ما وصفها بجهود الخاصه التي
تبذلها سلطنه عمان تجاه هذا الملف وكان
كنعاني قال امس في مؤتمر صحفي ان هناك
مفاوضات غير مباشره جاريه مع الولايات
المتحده لتبادل السجناء
الان الى معز بولحيه واخر اخبار الرياضه